um I wanted to know what sex felt like
so I took your manicure tool and I put
it
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
the first time that I tried masturbating
I ended up in the emergency room and it
happened because I went through this
super awkward party leading up to it
like when I was 15 that was the year
that all of my friends lost their
virginity and I was the only one who
hadn't yet so I felt really left out
like my friends would talk about their
favorite positions at lunch and I would
just bury myself in my sandwich like oh
cool anal I was so naive
I did very Lisa Simpson vibe in school
like a guy passed me a note in math
class that just said 69 on it and I
didn't know what that meant yet I
thought he was starting a math game with
me so I just built on to it I was like
69 divided by 3 is 23 your turn he was
like the not what you think this is
and I got teased for not knowing and I
just like I kind of snapped right like
there was too many things building up I
was so sick of feeling left out and
clueless and I was sick of waiting for a
boyfriend to lose my virginity to so I
got this crazy idea I was like okay I'm
gonna stick something up there so I
don't know what sex feels like and I can
feel cooler around my friends I know how
mentally unstable this sounds by the way
anytime you go the homemade dildo route
never a great idea but I was so
desperate to fit in that I just decided
to take matters into my own so you
know this is happening now so so I went
home from school and I decided to like
you know look around the house for an
object to lose my virginity to
you know and just like anyone's first
time I was super nervous and I went to
my mom's bathroom closet she was just
full of like phallic wonders right like
Sonicare toothbrush handles and
travel-size shampoo bottles but the
thing that really caught my eye was she
had this handheld manicure tool you can
put little attachments on top to like
buff your nails but the handle was
shaped like a dick well too much like a
dick by the way like whoever designed it
was definitely targeting curious teenage
girls and lonely housewives
it was bright blue it looked like Papa
Smurf's boner just oh it's so awkward
the only problem I didn't notice at the
time was that it was made of a grippy
rubber material yeah there's a little
four shot I went for it but again I knew
nothing about that hole and like what
should or shouldn't go in there so so I
draw my pants and I you know put my foot
up on the side of the tub as you do hi
sir weird for both of us and I I started
to try and you know like make this
happen but I'm not aroused by anything
that's going on frankly I'm terrified so
I'm as dry as a dead man's mouth
[Laughter]
my body is not helping me at all so that
combined with this grippy rubber
material it's like a kid trying to go
down an unsoaked slip and slide it's
just like nothing so I stop for a sec
and the same part of my brain is like
dude this is clearly not meant to be you
just need a way to have regular person
sex and then the crazy part of my brain
was like I'm not a quitter
Marty crouched over naked like Gollum
like we've come this far let's just
throw the Hail Mary so all of my
desperation to fit in fueled my tiny
pubescent wrists until I fit the
manicure tool all the way inside of me
and I just stood there frozen for a
second with enemy like oh and then I
throw it out here in the trash they got
in the shower like wash the shame off
and I knew that something was horribly
wrong right away as I started to feel a
burning and itching sensation I was like
oh okay I'll look at it with a
mirror and maybe it will look fine what
I saw in that mirror still haunts my
dreams to this day my crotch had swollen
shut closed like the bank on a Sunday my
looked like Rockies I turned
sideways
[Laughter]
yeah no bueno
so my stomach dropped I was like oh my
god
I need medical attention I'm gonna have
to tell a doctor exactly what I just did
but before that I'm gonna have to tell
my mom because I need somebody to drive
me to the doctor's office like my
puberty is just flashing before my eyes
everything's coming to an end so my mom
is in bed at this point she's doing like
a crossword puzzle or something magazine
I walk in pale as a ghost she sees me
she's like what's going on with you
what's wrong I was like uh
I don't know how to tell you this
because you're never gonna see me the
same way again she was like sweetie
nothing you tell me can make me stop
loving you I was like let's not say
things we can't take back I was like um
I wanted to know what sex felt like so I
took your manicure tool and I put
I put it inside me and now my vagina's
gone and my mom was like wow well we
were gonna have corn dogs for dinner but
now that seems like a safety hazard
[Laughter]
she's like right get in the car here we
go go to the doctor's office so we drove
down to the emergency clinic I grew up
in this tiny town I've been seeing the
same family doctor since I was like 5
years old he's this 60-year old
Christian man very Steve from Blue's
Clues type of energy not great for this
situation he has no idea how to handle
it he's just like okay Kelsey um we're
all a little confused as to what you did
something with an a manicure tool Susan
do you know no nobody knows okay do I
need to have a little look-see at your
undercarriage like just put me down like
an old animal oh my god I can't do this
so he straps on his miners headlight to
go spelunking for treasure and he goes
down and he pokes around with a q-tip a
little bit and he comes back um he's
like alright so you know from all the
swelling and burning and inflammation I
can deduce that you are allergic to
latex so you know going forward that
means no latex condoms no latex gloves
please don't do anything with balloon
animals
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I left the clinic that day with that
knowledge that I'm allergic to latex all
my future boyfriend's have been very
happy about that
right you know just high fives all
around no condoms just riddled with
disease unfortunately I didn't redeem my
awkward reputation at school you know I
did all that to try and fit in and
instead word spread around the school of
what happened and everybody was like hey
old Harry Bush made her disappear
check that up yeah the world's worst
magician over here how so embarrassed
like this haunted me for ten years I was
just mortified about it and I honestly
thought I was done with my latex
encounters until two years ago when I
moved to Los Angeles and I went to a new
doctor for my annual exam
I was lying back on the table he did the
whole like fingers inside your business
and then I sat up as he was taking his
gloves off and I was like oh no I was
like are those latex gloves he's like
yeah do you have an allergy and I was
like yeah he's like oh I'm so sorry
what happens when you come into contact
with it I was like my vagina tries to
kill itself he was like oh shoot okay
well there's not much I can do for you
right now I'm I can prescribe you some
cream that you can spread down there
it's like it's not a bagel
want to do that so he writes me this
prescription and he walks out and I'm
just standing there so pissed I'm like
there's no way I'm going through this
again like there has to be a way around
this
so my survival instincts kicked in and I
locked the doctor's office store behind
me and I got another crazy idea I was
like okay I'm in a masturbate because if
I can make myself come I might be able
to flush out the allergens before a
reaction starts I think Bill Nye would
be pretty proud of my plan there's
obviously no scientific research behind
this at all but I just like I just have
to try this I have to go for it I'm also
standing there like I can't believe that
10 years ago I tried masturbating and I
gave myself an allergic reaction and now
I'm gonna masturbate to try to not have
an allergic reaction really a decade of
doing the Lord's work this one so I'm
racing against the clock at this point
like this reaction is coming so I draw
my pants and I just like I close my eyes
I try to like find a way to be turned on
I just a picture that Channing Tatum's
behind me just like you know grinding it
out to some pony by genui and you know
just like really encouraging me and by
the power of Magic Mike I came and I did
not have an allergic reaction
[Applause]
yeah sometimes you got to be your own
douche and now I think I should get the
letters RX tattooed on these two fingers
they're the only prescription I need